is someone in the organization maybe
doing it possibly but it's not like you
understand what Barack Obama wasn't
holding a gun to kill Osama Bin Laden it
was seals who were doing it there were
people in the organization who put that
or put that whole thing together it's
not Barack Obama who was literally doing
it so I do I I don't know I really don't
okay my God tells me it's like it's
easier to believe that it is true but
it's not true I don't know I mean I
guess he doesn't have to I was just
curious dude it's really hard to be a
political conservative person and then
have all these [__] conspiracy
theories that like you have to deal with
like it's crazy like no dude it's I
don't know I just want to get two down
so I'm sure I'm gonna end up on some
stream getting yelled at by a bunch of
people but like it's just like I said
before
Hillary Clinton can be a terrible
president and not eat babies at the same
time both things can be true I didn't
even hear the eating baby yeah they said
she drinks adrenochrome from babies and
all this I've heard that but about
Hollywood
I mean I don't know it's not like my dad
when I tell him these conspiracy
theories that's what he says
so before because I'm gonna get so much
hate for all the stuff I just said okay
before I go any further let me say this
let's say all of it's true let's say
there really are lizard people who live
under Antarctica do they think there's
lizard people have you not heard this
yeah let's say let's say George Soros
and Hillary Clinton a drink adrenal
Chrome let's say all that stuff is true
yeah that's the reason why you live on
your mom's basement is that the reason
yeah because the Illuminati
no you live in your mom's basement
because you're a [__] loser that the
one of the things I love that Andrew
Tate said is that he said there's a
matrix and I just learned how to
manipulate the Matrix for me
whether it doesn't matter who president
United States is if you think he's a
[__] Android or a Democrat or if he's
Bernie or whoever is that the excuse why
you're fat is that the excuse why you're
broke is that the excuse I don't care
who the president is I'm still gonna be
rich and in shape I'm not going to make
excuses so if you want to believe in
conspiracy theories that's fine but when
you do it in order to hey either try to
get a bunch of views or two because
you're trying to make copes for your own
failures in life that's where I see it
to be in a problem yeah like there are
real uh conspiracies that nobody talks
about how about the Tuskegee experiments
where they're letting men have syphilis
African-American men have syphilis in
Alabama for years they had they had
antibiotics back in the 1930s and they
were just letting these men die of
syphilis for years how about the Iran
Contra affair where they were like
shipping crack cocaine into California
we don't talk about real conspiracies oh
wow but we talk about the ones MK Ultra
we know that the CIA was giving people
like mind-altering drugs they're real
conspiracies out there but we're still
stuck on Bush playing 911 like what the
[__] are we doing yeah one of my
favorite things was Julian Assange with
the whole Wikileaks thing he comes out
and he he said dude I've just given you
millions of [__] emails I give you
all this evidence and you get guys are
still stuck on Bush playing 911. I have
no evidence to support that whatsoever
there's so many other conspiracies that
are actually out there that you guys
don't want to worry about because they
don't involve lizard people you know
what I'm saying yeah that's the issue
I'm sorry like that yeah okay we're
going way too far down this what I do
want to talk about is this one of the
things that you said that was an
inflection point for you like you said
before you're trying to Red Pill one of
your friends yeah which I think is
awesome yeah right
you said that there was getting attacked
by whales oh the whale attack yes so
there's multiple like apparently there
was one main one and then there was
multiple others well no I mean you know
I do go in kind of hard on the fat
chicks yes I know I know they get mad at
me for this the original whale this is
how the whales started okay I I was
doing Street interviews okay and I was
doing Street interviews with these two
ladies now one was in shape one was
a whale yes yes okay and so what
happened was she
um I was talking about safety like she
was doing that thing women say oh I
can't walk home alone at night and it's
like blah blah blah and so I was just
like well why don't you just not walk
home alone at night you're not entitled
to safety you know I mean it'd be nice
if we have it but it's not like you know
men can't walk home alone at night
either and then this really triggered
her so she just knocks the mic out of my
hand and she's trying to attack me
luckily I had a guy with me she's like
which was interesting cause he was
talking about the men attack and I'm
like you're attacking me right now and
she's like I'll have you you slag I'll
have you and I'm going like this because
my friend was like holding her back you
know yes and I didn't know what a slag
was so if you don't know that is a hoe
poor yeah yes it's a UK version of a yes
and I I didn't know what that meant at
the time but I knew I was being insulted
Mike I was like yes I'm being insulted
right now and so then I was just like
well you're a whale and that was how it
started so then I just started like
blanketly calling like fat chicks and I
don't mean the nice fat chicks I mean
the fat chicks that throw their blubber
in their face and so then I did some
tick tocks going after the fat chicks
they started harassing my family one
kept calling my mother one got my mom's
phone number kept calling her well yeah
and they just it's a very um so the
second attack was a virtual attack
really
um but yeah I've only been physically
attacked once okay well so in that in
that situation you mentioned that that
video got taken down so they didn't care
about the part about this woman
attacking you they cared about the part
about you calling her a whale I guess
yeah I lost my first Tick Tock account I
almost had a million followers and that
video was on there that was the one that
got me taken down you still have it
somewhere do you have it posted anywhere
it's on YouTube it's on um I think they
actually re-clipped it recently and just
blurred the lady out because on YouTube
it got taken down because of a privacy
complaint Tick Tock it got banned but
it's on Jessie Praises Channel if you
guys look them up that's what she talked
into a microphone right what she talked
into the microphone so yeah that's legal
consent yeah I don't know that's what I
said too um and she actually
she was pretty drunk so I kept trying to
tell her either get in the shot or get
out of it because she kept coming in and
out and I was just like like lady either
get in or get out like I don't and so I
actually told her to get out it's like
she kept coming in the shot I was like I
don't care you're not that you're not
hot enough for that yes like I can go
get a hotter chick to interview like
it's not yeah so I couldn't believe they
took it down but yeah that's how the
whales started what was their reaction
afterwards
yeah I mean it went super viral yeah
um until they deleted the video off my
channel but it went pretty vile I got
like I don't remember how many views it
got but it got my friend monetized on
YouTube so wow yeah so he was happy uh
did that have an effect on your audience
that went to YouTube
uh not really it was like the same
audience okay because it was like asking
about I can't remember what exactly we
did the video on but it was it was
something with like red pill type
content so who you mentioned before the
people who trigger get triggered the
most by your content are who you just
think it's like you mentioned before you
thought it was girls who had a high body
count or girls who
um
feminists yeah I would just say General
feminist probably the one I mean I do
use the word whales a lot I kind of do
it to be funny but I I think it's kind
of funny so so yeah I would say whales
and feminists when when it comes to the
stuff you talk about on your show do you
think it's uh so like when I talk about
these Concepts I try to do it in a
descriptive you mentioned before like I
do a lot of research on the stuff that I
talk about yeah I try to describe what I
think the world is like but I don't try
to prescribe meaning I tell my friends
I'm like if you want to be a girl on
only fans who have sex with a guy on
only fans multiple guys you can do that
because you live in the United States
and you're free to do that but there's
going to be consequences and these
consequences are the pool of men that
you're gonna have to select from are
narrower and narrower and narrower and
when we start with men who are over six
feet tall six-pack abs you know not
obese and make over a hundred thousand
dollars a year we're only talking about
point three eight percent of men in the
United States so you start with that
number and it starts to shrink as you as
he realizes this woman is having sex on
only fans do you understand what I'm
saying when I just in the nicest
possible way try to express the
consequences to them there's no Jesus
you're sinning you're immoral I don't
call him a hoe none of that I just
explain the consequences yeah and I do
it mathematically I get called to
[__] misogynist and I'm like how is
this possible like and do your some of
these people are like my friends I'm
like how the [__] are you calling me a
misogynist for pointing out numbers to
you
yeah I mean I mean I just think it's
when they don't really have an argument
to be I mean I don't really think it
matters how you say it to them I think
they'll be offended either way that's
one of the things that I thought was
interesting is like I start off the art
just as an experiment I'll start off the
argument by literally saying you can do
whatever you want yeah you can do
whatever you want right you can be happy
there's a lot of money you can make
doing only fans I'm sure you can now
doing whatever you want here's the
possible consequences if you came to me
and said hey Michael you know you play
pick up basketball for 25 years your
knees might be [__] up I'm not gonna
go [__] you dude I can't believe you
said that to me piece of [__] yeah like
no I was like hey you know what this
probably you're probably right well I
just don't like I feel like older women
lie to the younger generation of women
okay and I just think I I what I hate is
I hate lying to girls and I just think
it's like dishonest to say you can just
do whatever you want and have no
consequence like it really pisses me off
I have three little sisters you know so
it's like you're gonna say you can just
do whatever you want there's no
consequences even though especially when
it's women over like a certain age where
they know deep down there are
consequences for those kind of things I
mean didn't that study just come out
that said like 90 or 80 of only fans
um workers like are content creators
it's yeah it's like 80 I think it was 80
to 90 of um guys or it was either it was
either 80 to 90 of only fans content
creators said they were rejected because
of it or 80 to 90 percent of like guys
said they would reject someone because I
don't remember probably the second one
yeah it was but because I'll tell you
right now those girls who make that
money on only fans do have boyfriends
they are getting in relationships yeah
one of two things happens either the guy
they're with has some other kind of
proclivity meaning like maybe he's
bisexual and he's fine with the content
creation or he's in content creation
also yeah or what's most likely is that
they have a man who like they lowered
their standards and picked the guy who
was very stable yeah and then eventually
they're going to leave him yeah that's
most again not all the time right I
definitely know some like one of the
things is when I made these comments I
have friends of mine that were married
and they both do only fans together and
I'm like I'm not talking about you you
guys are doing only fans together like
there's some girls that go in there they
don't even pose nude I'm not talking
girls who are literally doing hardcore
porn to make a buck and then I'm I'm
just mentioning that there might be some
consequences for this and I'm just
getting [__] hounded my girlfriend is
actually more Draconian about this than
me she's like I'll never have an only
chance any only fans I won't do anything
like that and she made it but she seems
awesome I saw her on whatever yeah she
seems so cool yeah she uh so she makes a
video and she in the in the video she
says I I found my dream man and he's
proof for me that because I don't have
an only fans I know that for me to get a
girl a guy like this I need to now have
an only fans right and the hate they're
literally calling her a misogynist for
saying this she can have that opinion
that's what was so crazy to me yeah well
and I just I I just really don't like
lying to younger women and I think a lot
of older women give younger women bad
advice because they're bitter about the
position that they're in and it's like I
I would rather like tell the next
generation of women like that that this
stuff will have consequences especially
because I just have three little sisters
yeah I just don't like I think what I
think what the issue is is there's very
little short-term consequence and when
you're in your feelings you don't think
about that because here's the thing I
think people are the way they are not
because of a lack of morality but it's a
lack of consequences and let's talk
about it on both sides yeah Jordan
Belfort
yeah Quaaludes prostitutes 15 or like 27
months in a federal prison all this
stuff is he more famous or less famous
after he commits the crime oh more
famous that man built a career you saw
the dude um from fire Festival what's
his name um fat or I've heard of him
yeah he goes on CNN the other day he's
doing fire Festival part two
the Tinder swindler is starting a
coaching program
isn't it horrible yeah yeah okay
O.J Simpson is about to get hired
because I talked to him about it he's
about to get hired to do a uh fantasy
football podcast okay
Oliver North who was part of the Iran
Contra affair was a correspondent for
Fox News
and when uh uh what's his name um Logan
Paul he goes in that forest and there's
that dead body up there and he violates
terms of service for
for uh YouTube he becomes more famous
afterwards remember he's canceled and he
does the fight with KSI now he's more
famous my point is no one pays for
anything short term
Pearl and so when when you have these
women and they're looking at it from a
situation where they see the glitz and
glamor of one thing but they don't see
any sort of long-term consequences I
think that's what the issue is it's not
there's no consequences there's no
there's no short term right I have a
question do you think women lie about
how much they make on only fans
um yeah I think a lot of them do but
some of them I could verify well because
I was there was a couple girls on the
show I was on them whatever where I
started like looking at it at like their
likes or whatever like one girl said she
made 70k a month and I was just looking
it up and I'm like you don't even have
like subscriptions on here yeah
um yeah and I was and I was looking up
the number of women on only fans that
made that amount of money it was like
point zero one percent I was like maybe
she is I don't know but you're right A
lot of them are lying because if they're
making 300K a month doesn't it make
their decision seem like it makes more
sense yeah because even some men are
gonna hear 300K a month and be like ah
okay I get it you know yeah and here's
another funny thing so I talked to them
and they may be coping they may be not
telling the truth but I talked to a lot
of them and when they do make 100K a
month or 200k a month and they buy a new
house in a nice car they tell me that
there's this point to where their
parents are like okay I can see you're
making good money from this and they're
like okay with it now I don't know if
they're telling the truth I'm just gonna
just gonna take them out their word but
there is a point where is it 500 000 a
month at what point is it now then okay
to do this and then what are you giving
up in the future right Playing devil's
advocate 500 000 a month is a lot of
money yeah there's a certain amount of
happiness you can't buy with that yeah
you understand what I'm saying I'm like
that's a lot of money yeah I know
several I probably I know at least 10
girls who make 300K a month wow and I
talked to them about this whole
situation and it's really interesting
like from everything from like their
entire lifestyle is now a tax write-off
everything they do is a tax right off
which is crazy yeah um and then and then
when you ask them to come on your show
whatever fresh and fit they immediately
say yes they'll fly out so it's
Stephanie well will they tell them to
come on Stephanie Stephanie palomares oh
dude I'll tell uh yeah UK will come uh
hit up um uh you know the tally you know
the the guide Vitali who used to make
the prank videos on you YouTube
uh his girlfriend's Delia Rose I bet she
lives in Manchester I bet she'll come on
your show she's like yeah yeah I don't
know her but so so
um I forgot what my original point was
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible